well since the chronovirus pandemic
began artist ai weiwei has launched
himself into creative and humanitarian
projects
in june he raised over 1 million pounds
selling face coverings he designed to
help support the work of global
charities fighting coronavirus
and now he's unveiled his latest work at
the imperial war museum
history of bombs is a display of 50
life-size bombs that replicate those
jews and conflicts
in wars over the last 100 years and ai
weiwei
joins me now from berlin many thanks
indeed for joining us
this morning um this artwork is said to
draw on your
ongoing investigation into politics and
power um
firstly why did you decide to get
involved with the imperial war museum
i think it's a very good location and
for many reasons it focuses on the
the military uh
practice uh of the history and
there's so much to be uh
learned and also so many uh so many
things need to be aware
of what has been uh
going on in our human
modern history or
in in you know this kind of politics
because the war is the extreme of the
political
struggle and i think this is a chance
for us to do
a real study to see what has been
physically produced and by whom and the
uh other what kind of historical
a reason or meaning so what will people
see
when they go to the exhibition and also
what would you like them to experience
i think as an artist you you transform
your feeling or your consciousness
into a physical
expression which means either in writing
or in
art objects or in the public space
so that kind of
this kind of possibility would
build up some kind of discussion and
you know people cannot you you do think
people need to be aware
and those things have to be physically
almost like touchable or you stand on it
you know
and those are real size bonds and
you only hear it from news but
to to at this kind of close range and
it means very different
this also comes at a time when the
imperial war museum is
exploring the experience of refugees
this is
something that is personal to you your
father was banished to a forced labor
camp in
1957 you yourself grew up in exile
yes i think the refugee situation has
become even more extreme than
years ago when i just got involved doing
the film
human flow and now the number uh
still going up we can see many many
refugees
probably most of them i've been pushed
out of home
by wars so refugees directly tell me
why they have to move because those
bombs comes down like a dream
so that i still remember that sentence
which is unthinkable how they survived
and the but the dizzy will survive
and once they come to a safe ground
i don't think they it really survived
they just uh you know there's very
little
concern in today's uh global politics
about their conditions and on the points
of the conditions of
people interesting to get your thoughts
about the situation currently in hong
kong we've seen the arrests of
pro-democracy activists we've also seen
the disqualification
of people from the um legislative
election process i mean what do you make
of
the crackdown that we are seeing um in
hong kong
china uh using this national security
law
i think uh what happens in hong kong
yesterday or today you know a few uh
youngsters
among 16 to 21 years old they are just
posting some
internet posts
under being arrested those just the
first
drops of the water of a heavy rain
in the national security law it has
been practiced in china for past
many many decades under this kind of law
which
makes sure make sure this authoritarian
state
can function and the under that
function bring china to to this most
powerful one of the most powerful for
power i think that is the surviving
game chinese government government
is playing but to put it
in hong kong which versus such a
heavy-handed
law i think many many people
while facing uh to be either in jail
or exiled or to be silent
and you mentioned first drops of water
what about the last drops of water i
mean how bad could it get
um for people uh in hong kong and also
what does that mean for the relationship
between
china and the west
i think uh hong kong just will become
another uh province uh
in china that means uh any
uh freedom of speech or or
human rights condition are will be
very heavily restricted under chinese
law
so any new ideas or new
new voice will be crashed
last drop of water will be the ocean and
they they all be really sunken down
to the ocean a bleak picture that you
paint um
we are in the midst of the global
pandemic what do you
make of the way that china has dealt
with information surrounding
kv19 i think it's
obviously china had made a mistake at
the early stage
and i really think they should admit it
because anybody can make up stage but
only china cannot afford of
admitting these kind of
problems you know this has been causing
them so much
of their credibility and the hong kong
international partners or in business
can trust them and to sing think they're
dependable
so that really have such heavy
cost i don't know why they don't
understand this situation
just to be transparent to have a
transparency
and to to be honest which is always
difficult
not only in china but but still china
for hiding up the information or
distort those information has been
causing a huge
problem for the world ayeway really good
to get your thoughts many thanks indeed
for joining us um this morning here on
the sky news thank you
thank you